das hier ist die neueste wahrscheinlich
kleinste kamera der welt wie klein na ja
so klein das heißt vieles von dem was
diese kamera hier kann kann auch diese
kamera hier aber wie so oft bei coolen
neuen erfindungen ist die frage ist das
etwas was nur im labor funktioniert oder
wird man sowas wirklich mal irgendwann
kaufen können und darin sieht es
tatsächlich ganz gut aus man ist
zuversichtlich dass die metas service
wie sie genannt wird tatsächlich einmal
ein produkt wird aber ist kleiner
wirklich immer besser und wie
funktioniert diese revolutionäre
technologie überhaupt genau das
beantworten wir jetzt bei dr watson
let's go
[Musik]
das hier war die wahrscheinlich kleinste
kamera der welt im jahr 2011 warum
erzähle ich euch das na ja einerseits um
eine ausrede zu haben euch dieses bild
zeigen zu können denn das sieht ja
irgendwie lustig aus oder man weiß nicht
so richtig auf das ein riesiger finger
oder eine kleine kamera ist aber
andererseits zeigt diese mini kamera
auch sehr gut wo das problem liegt wenn
kameras aber eigentlich auch viele
andere technologische geräte immer
kleiner werden wollen erstens gibt es so
weniger platz für batterien dieser
kleine dslr nachbau hat zum beispiel nur
30 minuten akku und zweitens bleibt
natürlich auch weniger platz für die
komponenten die qualitativ hochwertige
fotos wirklich machen in diesem fall war
nur für eine auflösung von 1600 x 1200
pixeln platz und das sieht dann so aus
natürlich sind pixel nicht alles was
qualität angeht aber generell können wir
es glaube ich einigen dass diese mini
kamera jetzt nicht die beste foto
qualität aller zeiten hat aber klar seit
2011 hat sich auch einiges getan zum
beispiel ist einfach der wahnsinn was
für eine krasse kamera man mittlerweile
in seiner hosentasche mit sich
rumschleppt oder auch was bloß
inzwischen für eine unglaubliche
bildqualität hat aber egal ob die kamera
in meinem smartphone oder einer gopro
das ist alles viel viel größer als ein
salzkorn und klar hier muss es natürlich
qualitative abstriche geben aber
gegenüber vergleichbaren kameras die
ähnlich gute bilder die die salzkorn
kamera machen ist das 1 5
hunderttausendfacher größenunterschied
der technische fortschritt der letzten
jahre und jahrzehnte ist einfach immer
wieder unglaublich ein sehr spannendes
buch in dem es um die erfindung von
mikrochips software und algorithmen geht
ist übrigens die innovatives von walter
isaacson
da geht es zum beispiel darum wem wir
überhaupt moderne computer oder auch das
freie internet zu verdanken haben und
vor allem wie im silicon valley so viele
innovationen in so kurzer zeit
stattfinden konnten das ist ein sehr
spannendes buch aber wer hat schon die
zeit mal eben so ein ganzes buch zu
lesen und genau hier kommt unser
heutiger sponsor blinkt ist ins spiel
wenn ich schon länger doktor watson
videos schaut dann wisst ihr wir
arbeiten uns super gerne tief in die
verschiedensten themen rein manchmal ist
das aber sehr zeitaufwendig und deswegen
benutzen wir link ist denn blinkt ist
fast ganze bücher in 15 minütige text
und audio erklärer zusammen insgesamt
sind hier über 4.500 sachbücher und
podcasts aus den bereichen physik
ernährung persönliche entwicklung
technik und zukunft zu finden und ich
mag blinkt ist wirklich gerne vor allem
wenn es darum geht schnell aber trotzdem
faktenbasiert in ein thema einzusteigen
dann ist die app einfach wahnsinnig
praktisch falls ihr blick ist auch schon
immer mal ausprobieren wollte aber euch
nicht so ganz sicher seid ob das ganze
wirklich was für euch ist ihr könnt
komplett kostenlos und ohne gefahr
sieben tage lang alle möglichen bücher
auf linkes testen und jederzeit kündigen
und falls ihr das angebot an gut findet
dann könnt ihr aufblinken punkt de /
doktor watson 25 prozent rabatt auf ein
jahres abo blickes prämie bekommen und
damit auch noch unseren kanal hier
unterstützen klickt einfach auf den
ersten link unten in der video
beschreibung und fangt an zu lernen
danke anblick ist für die unterstützung
bei diesem video und jetzt geht es
weiter mit der kleinsten kamera der welt
die salzkorn kamera nutzt keine
gebogenen linsen wie zb herkömmliche
kameras aus glas oder plastik sondern
eine sogenannte meta service und nein
das ist nicht die neue kooperation von
microsoft und facebook obwohl die mit
dem ganzen dinge auch was zu tun haben
aber dazu kommen wir später so eine meta
service enel zumindest optisch keinem
tablet sondern eher einem computer chip
tatsächlich ist die service wenn man
genauer hinschaut so etwas wie ein
kleiner antennen park auf der oberfläche
von nur einem halben millimeter breite
sind 1,6 millionen kleine stäbchen
angebracht und weil es schwierig ist
sich vorzustellen wie klein das wirklich
ist das bedeutet dass eins dieser
stäbchen so groß ist wie ein hi virus
partikel einen durchmesser von gerade
mal 100 nanometern diese meter service
antennen sind aussieht jung nitrit ganz
vereinfacht gesagt ist das ein glas
ähnliches material das auch ziemlich
robust ist aber wie robust 1,6 millionen
winzige stäbchen sind wir nicht da
aussehen mit meinem finger dran komme
das haben die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in der studie leider
nicht erklärt aber naja zurück zum thema
die idee so einer meta service ist gar
nicht neu schon 2018 wurde dass das
erste mal im labor umgesetzt nur sagen
die fotos da eben noch so aus die
neueste version der mieterservice macht
solche fotos die farben sind inzwischen
kräftiger und mit 720 x 720 pixeln ist
das immerhin hd ready ja ich weiß das
ist jetzt keine
360° 500k auflösung hdr 300 bilder pro
sekunde slow motion level von qualität
aber das ist trotzdem wie ich persönlich
finde ganz schön beeindruckend ersten
und 2 naja die kameras halt echt nur so
groß wie ein salzkorn und zweitens
dieser sprung was die qualität angeht
war nur durch künstliche intelligenz
möglich wenn nicht mit einer
herkömmlichen kamera ein foto schießen
möchte dann gibt es zwei zentrale
komponenten die dafür wichtig sind
erstens das objektiv welches das
einfallende licht und bündelt und
zweitens den bildträger auf dem dieses
licht in ein bild umgewandelt wird
früher waren das noch filme mit
sensiblen chemikalien die sehr
spezifisch mit verschiedenen
wellenlängen des lichts reagieren um so
ein farbbild erzeugen heute erledigen
das meistens digitale bildsensoren die
das licht in elektrische impulse
umwandeln aus denen sich dann ein bild
pixel für pixel zusammensetzt ein ganz
ähnlicher sensor ist auch in unserer
mini kamera verbaut viel spannender ist
hier aber das objektiv oder die matter
optik das stichwort ist polarisation das
beschreibt die richtung in der eine
lichtwelle schwingt und je nachdem auf
welche oberflächen das licht trifft
ändert sich die polarisation diese
wellen und ihre unterschiede je nach
oberfläche sind für das menschliche auge
meistens unsichtbar aber mit der
richtigen technik einfangen bar und hier
kommt die meta service ins spiel jedes
dieser kleinen stückchen auf der meta
service hat eine einzigartige form
trifft licht auf die stäbchen dann
sortieren sie quasi die polarisation der
szene oder anders gesagt diese antennen
park fängt die schwingungen des lichts
vom motiv dass man fotografieren möchte
ein diese informationen werden dann an
einen dekon volution algorithmus
weitergegeben dessen aufgabe ist es dann
ganz vereinfacht gesagt das bild das zu
diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht wirklich
erkennbar ist scharf zu machen und auch
wenn das alle super zeitaufwendig klingt
dauert es gerade mal 58 sekunden so ein
foto zu machen
in einem video erklären die
verantwortlichen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler des prinzen
computational imagine labs auch nochmal
genauer wie der prozess funktioniert und
zeigen sogar kurze video aufnahmen mit
der kamera den link dazu findet ihr
unten in der video beschreibung all das
haben frühere versionen einer meta
service kamera auch schon ähnlich
gemacht aber damals mussten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
im trial and error verfahren quasi von
hand diese winzigen antennen bauen
anordnen und wenn es nicht geklappt hat
wieder von vorne beginnen das ergebnis
brauchbare fotos gab es nur unter
absolut perfekten lichtbedingungen aber
jetzt gab es einen durchbruch wird bei
der salzkorn kamera an zwei stellen
genutzt einmal zur verarbeitung der
lichtsignale aber auch schon vorher um
die dafür zuständige meter service
überhaupt erst zu designen anstatt
selber von hand nanostrukturen immer
wieder auszuprobieren ist diese neue
meter service von einer
computersimulation designt worden
perfekt sehen diese aufnahmen natürlich
noch nicht aus gerade wenn man sie mit
fotos einer herkömmlichen kamera
vergleicht sieht man ganz klar dass da
kein spiel ist aber ich finde alleine
der fortschritt von 2018 bis heute macht
hoffnung dass wir eines tages vielleicht
wirklich einmal mit solchen micro
kameras arbeiten könnten wenn ihr auch
so ein kamera der zeit wie ich dann sagt
er jetzt bestimmt alles klar herr damit
und was kostet das dann eigentlich
natürlich braucht es ein bisschen bis
neue technologie vom labor in die regale
kommt die forscherinnen und forscher
rechnen aber damit dass so eine
mieterservice in der produktion viel
günstiger sein könnte als eine normale
kamera da der materialaufwand minimal
ist aber ob wann und für wie viele taler
man dass man als produkt kaufen kann das
steht leider noch in den sternen und wie
schnell man diese dinge verlieren karte
das will ich mir auch gar nicht erst
vorstellen trotzdem ist das mega cool
und eigentlich auch viel mehr als nur
ein gadget oder eine spielerei kameras
und besonders sehr kleine kameras sind
für die wissenschaft super wichtig um da
hinzuschauen wo das menschliche auge an
seine grenzen gerät aber auch für die
therapie und diagnose von krankheiten 3
für medizinerinnen und mediziner oft auf
indus kopie zurück heißt so ein ding
wird über eine körperöffnung deiner wahl
eingeführt damit man sich zb einen damen
einen magen oder die speiseröhre genau
anschauen kann klingt es sind genau und
fun fact so oder so ähnlich konnten
archäologen auch herausfinden was die
letzte und wahrscheinlich auch tödliche
mahlzeit vom fc war weitere use cases
von solchen kameras sind aber auch zum
beispiel die rettung von verschütteten
bei katastrophen mit so einer meta
service kamera könnte man ähnliche dinge
machen nur eben noch mal kleiner
leichter transportabler und hoffentlich
auch günstiger die forscherinnen und
forscher haben sich sogar hinreißen
lassen mal ein bisschen zu träumen was
in zukunft mit solchen kameras alles
möglich sein wird und eine sache fanden
wir hier besonders spannend in zukunft
könnten oberflächen mit hunderten
kleinen meter services ausgestattet
werden die alle zusammenarbeiten
das heißt dass mein smartphone
vielleicht in der zukunft irgendwann
nicht mehr drei linsen hat sondern
vielleicht dutzende meter surfaces die
komplett auf der rückseite verteilt sind
die man dabei gar nicht mehr als kamera
erkennen würde ich finde ja das klingt
alles schon ein bisschen nach
agentenfilmen und das ist doch gar nicht
so weit hergeholt geheimdienste und
militär sind natürlich auch an winzigen
hightech kameras interessiert aber
ständig unbemerkt gefilmt werden und
alle möglichen flächen mit kameras
ausstatten das klingt nach einem sehr
dystopischen zukunftsszenario das könnte
auch erklären warum unter anderem das
us-verteidigungsministerium genau dieses
projekt unterstützt weitere namhafte
unterstützer sind übrigens amazon google
und wie vorhin schon erwähnt facebook
beziehungsweise jetzt meter und
besonders für das geplante metallbauers
von meta also eine verschmelzung von vw
und realität sind die meta services
natürlich sehr interessant warum die
ganze news rund um das metall war es
übrigens ziemlich fragwürdig sind das
haben wir in diesem video hier schon
erklärt dass könnt euch ja noch mal
anschauen ansonsten wie immer vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
mal bleibt neugierig patrick